what do you think
I think it's it's deeply shocking and
concerning uh these allegations and you
know there is an investigation underway
um so I would want to limit speculation
on the investigation but I think once
the investigation has happened and once
we know what the facts of the matter are
there are questions to be asked here um
about what the BBC has done and the
delay that seems to have taken place
um in them taking action on this is it
right that the BBC marked their own
homework or should it be an independent
investigation
that's a good question and I'm going to
think at the moment let's let the BBC do
their investigation into what's happened
but I think further down the line we
need to ask questions about that process
at the BBC because you know we've got to
have trust in the BBC that their
processes are in place and certainly the
delay that's being reported you know is
very concerning so I think those
processes need to be looked at once the
investigation is concluded
okay um
talk to me I mean we can we're taking
the mom's word for it why would we not
at this stage she contacted the BBC to
say please stop your presenter giving
this money to my child who is a crack
addict please stop because otherwise
they will die and according to her why
would we not believe her but according
to her she says more payments were made
so that would suggest that potentially
the BBC presenter was not spoken to
Beggars believe this I I mean when I
hear stuff like that child I mean when
you hear when you hear stuff like that
you know and obviously we the
investigation needs to conclude and we
need to make sure we don't speculate too
much on it but it's really concerning
and that's why I think that once the
investigation has concluded we need to
take a step back and look at the process
you know what has happened in terms of
the delay has the BBC acted quick enough
making sure the BBC is responding the
right way to these very serious
allegations and what do you make of the
fact that
yeah it's it's an interesting question
about the presenting not being named
because on the one hand you know I can
understand that whilst an investigation
is underway and you want to make sure
that that is concluded before the name
comes out in public but on the other
hand you know the BBC needs to show that
they are being taken this seriously and
taking the right precautions and also
you don't want other presenters
necessarily to be implicated because
they haven't been named as being not the
person who's the subject of the
investigation so it's a it's a balancing
act and I don't think there's an easy
way through this but I think what is
important is the BBC concludes its
investigation as quickly as possible and
that actually is part of this broader
question about the processes of the BBC
you know why is there a delay you know
why are they not have did they not get
on with this quicker and now is underway
they need to do it as quickly as
possible to clear up this confusion
about who it might be
but
is this an exception because it's a
public figure
who is known
to most of the country
that is paid for by an organization that
receives public money is there not a
justification to know who that person is
well what I would say about it being the
BBC and it being a public institution
that we all pay for and that's why we
need to have trust in their processes
and so that's why you know let's let
them do their investigation they should
damage that trust I think issue
questions like this you know do shake
the trust a little bit in the BBC when
you hear things a little bit well I
think let's let's let's see the detail
of it as I say I'm being careful not to
speculate too much because I want to see
the detail about exactly what happened
when
um but I think certainly in terms of the
timeline when you look at the Timeline
you know when you hear what's been said
and so on there seems to be on the face
of it a case to look at about all the
processes in place there and we need to
make sure those processes at the BBC are
solid and we can now trust in them
because as you say they're our national
broadcasts that we all pay for them you
know we need to make sure that they have
the processes in place which we can rely
on if this timeline's accurate it's an
absolute outrage I mean the timeline
does like does look shocking and that's
why it needs to be looked into and I
think that that part of the process once
the current investigation is included
and that part of the process needs to be
looked at thoroughly okay
um talk to me a little bit uh more
detail if you would please um about
um what we've been hearing from uh the
chancellor or what we will be hearing
from the chancellor later on today I
think he's speaking it at mansion house
isn't he what does he need to say to get
you on side
well I'm not sure exactly you can't say
anything yeah so I think I think my mind
is probably made up when I go into that
room but you know in the interest of the
country you know what he needs to be
doing is get getting the economy growing
because we've had 13 years of low growth
in the economy um you know we need to
make sure the economy is growing we need
to make sure we have that investment
that we need in getting the future
Industries the future uh in into the
country and making sure we've got jobs
in every part of the UK but actually you
know I suspect there's little or nothing
the chancellor can say to really
reassure people because they've had 13
years we've had low growth for those 13
years if they haven't got any new ideas
and actually even if he says something
tonight I don't think people would
believe they have the uh the uh the
strength in Parliament to get any of
their ideas through and to hold hold the
show together okay it's good to talk to
you thanks very much really appreciate
it thank you